And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
We'll get to your questions here that you submitted.
Remember, for anybody who has to do,
submit your questions on the member site.
So the Zoom call is for full members.
Our kids are playing.
And you can ask questions anytime you want,
best to just submit those questions on our member site.
If you think of them, while we're doing this Zoom call,
you think of a new question, anything new,
go ahead and chat it in or unmute yourself at the end
when I'm done with the questions that were submitted
and feel free to verbalize a question in.
OK, remember to turn your video off.
So we don't want anybody on video here.
All right, now the reminder to look at the member site
for any fluid elements.
Let's jump to the first question.
First question, how often should a person do new blood work?
Well, that's completely dependent upon what's going on
with the person's treatment plan
and what's going on with previous blood work.
So if you've had previous blood work that has been abnormal,
then you should do it more frequently.
Also depends on the person's current state of health.
Let's say you're currently feeling great,
but you had some abnormalities, let's say,
and your liver enzymes were slightly elevated.
How often should you do new blood work?
Well, then you factor in other things.
Well, I'm not doing chemotherapy,
which can greatly affect my liver enzymes.
I'm not doing fentanyzol, or I'm erectin
that can greatly affect your liver enzymes.
And that past trend was just a slight slow elevation
of those liver enzymes.
Well, maybe you're going to wait a month,
depending on the trend, the previous trend.
If you were doing it monthly,
maybe you're going to wait two months,
maybe you're going to wait three months.
But it depends on all these different factors.
So if your current state of health is good,
and your last blood work was good, you were doing it.
Let's say every three months,
and it would spend normal, normal, normal, normal.
And you're still doing well.
Maybe you could wait six months.
It's everybody's different.
So you have to assess that as an individual.
Next question.
Is it okay for a cancer patient to eat meat?
I heard someone say that anyone with cancer
should be vegan.
You see a lot of those claims out there,
even by sources that are trying to be coaches
of people that have cancer,
say that everybody should do this
or everybody should do that.
Now, there are some general everybody should do
if you have cancers like even if you didn't have cancer,
everybody should be eating less sugar
or everybody should be eating less grains
or everybody should be trying to eat organic.
I mean, those are a given just natural understanding
of trying to stay away from toxins,
trying to stay away from things
that raise your blood glucose levels,
trying to stay as healthy as possible.
So that is a given.
But when you classify it down like everybody
who has cancer should go on a ketogenic diet.
Well, that's just not correct
or everybody who has cancer should go on a meat-free diet,
which is basically the opposite of a ketogenic diet.
Should go vegan.
You hear that out there.
Everybody with cancer should be juicing 12 glasses
of juice, who vegetables you today
or everybody of cancer should go on a raw food diet.
Those are, I think, very incorrect statements
because everybody with cancer is different.
And everybody with cancer, their cancer can change
and different things can be feeding the cancer.
So if you went on a vegan diet, the dangers of a vegan diet
is that you're not getting enough protein
in order to make T cells and natural killer cells
that are essential for killing cancer.
So often you'll see people on a vegan diet
that do well and very often you see people
on a vegan diet whether they have cancer or not,
that look horrible.
Their health is suffering greatly.
So to be on a specific diet because it's a fan,
I think it's very, be on a specific diet
because you just heard a video on Instagram
that said everybody should do this.
I think it's foolishness.
And the same thing with ketogenic diets.
Ketogenic diet, good for everybody.
Well, no, it may not be.
So you just want to get as specific as possible
and that's going to be the best way as far as you're going
to treat cancer is everyone is different.
And you need a protocol that's specific to you
as an individual, not in some generality
because, you know, I got healed
at a vegan diet that means everybody
that I talked to should be on a vegan diet.
That's narcissism.
That's, no, honestly, you know,
and you see a lot of practitioners do that.
Okay, with my cancer, meat did drive my cancer.
So I stayed off of meat.
I don't know.
And, you know, I think there was parts of me
that suffered because I was on a more vegan diet
while I was in the throes of my cancer.
But there's parts of it that helped
because I, you know, got tested
and meat wasn't driver for my cancer.
So I had to stay away from it.
But then there got to a point where it wasn't anymore.
And I was able to go back to eat it
and my health improved in other ways because of that.
So going on a strict diet that you're eliminating certain food
groups, wherever the Bible says that God made everything
to be good for man to eat when He created it.
Now, of course, we as humans have distorted a lot of things.
So what do we do?
We want to eat grass fed meat as much as organic grass fed meat
as much as possible or wild caught salmon as much as possible.
So you do your best to try to eat things that are clean,
but you don't follow fat diets.
You don't listen to Instagram influencers.
You don't even listen to practitioners who are giving one size
fits all to everybody.
I just think that's wrong.
You want to be very specific to you as an individual
and get tested individually.
What could be driving your cancer?
And that's what you want to stay away from
is just what's driving your cancer.
Next question.
My insurance was covered by lab tests.
Now they want different codes.
Can you provide these?
So if you do your lab tests through us and you have insurance,
let's say I'm Medicare, let's say, can we provide the code
so you could submit to Medicare?
No, we can't.
So you can't, you cannot submit two insurance through our clinic.
So you'll have to go to a practitioner that's local.
If you want to submit to insurance and while that is a provider
within your network, Medicare doesn't have necessarily a network.
But then you have to go to a provider that accepts Medicare
and can, you know, if it's Medicare, if it's group health or that,
you know, whatever it is, you have to go to Blue Cross Bushield
provider doctor.
If you have Blue Cross Bushield, you want it to be provided.
The doctor that submitting these for me want some kind
of documentation now.
If I'm going to have to start paying, what tests do I really need
or just get the same as before?
So that kind of plays off the first question.
How often do you have to get blood tests?
Now you can, you know, if you want to do the least expensive
tests that you have to do, you could just run tests
that would be more specific to markers that were elevated.
So let's, let's say, let's say my CBC and differential has been
normal, you know, I've been, let's say I'm getting lamb tests
every month for the last year.
And now my insurance is blocking at paid for it.
And I'm going to have to pay on a pocket and I don't want to pay
$300 a month to run monthly lab tests on a pocket.
Can I narrow it down to just test the things that were
abnormal?
The answer is yes, you can.
So it can become much less expensive.
So as an example, let's say my CBC and differential has been
normal the last six months.
The only thing that's been elevated is, let's pretend it's
alcohol and phosphatase.
Alcohol and phosphatase has been level has been abnormal.
And it's been elevated.
And I am on fed bin.
So I do want to keep an eye on it.
Can I just run an alcohol and phosphatase test?
Well, no, but you could just run a comprehensive metabolic
profile, which would be far less expensive.
You could probably do that for, you know, 50 bucks.
And if it's trend, if it's staying level, you might be able to
spread out, you know, the frequency at which you're getting the
test done.
So again, like the question before about how often a person
should get blunt tests, it depends on a lot of factors.
It depends on what you're doing as far as treatment goes.
It depends on how you're feeling subjective data.
It depends on, you know, the levels that were abnormal and to
the jury, those those tests were abnormal.
So we'd have to factor in all those, but you can narrow
down.
Well, I don't need to run a PSA test again.
My PSA is normal.
I don't even have prostate cancer.
So why am I paying for that thing?
Yes, we can narrow down and do less things and it can be
less expensive.
Next question.
What are your thoughts on using colostrum with growth factors
for someone with hormone positive breast cancer?
Clostrum is a common supplement these days.
Clostrum does have growth factors.
Clostrum is going to be a a dairy based product and it does
have growth factors.
And that's really the benefit of it.
It can help heal your gut and things.
So it's typically not recommended for anybody with any type
of cancer.
Now, if you had to take colostrum for a shorter time to help
something else, I don't see that as a real problem, but
to be honest, while you're in the throes of cancer, there
can be dangers to that.
Now, I would say also that, you know, if it depends on where
you're at with your cancer with any of these two, even with
glutamine, let's say your cancer is in full remission, which
have really damaged gut.
And you want to take glutamine for a short period of time.
Is it okay to do that?
Well, yes, probably.
I mean, there's no way to absolutely know whether it's going
to be in a perfect situation for anybody.
But using common sense, if you're trying to accomplish another
task with a product for a short period of time, if you're going
to take colostrum because you read this thing, they'll be
really good for you.
And you want to be on it on a regular basis if use, if your
cancer is a complete remission, I would think twice about that.
But if you, if your cancer wasn't complete remission, you
were doing really well.
I mentioned how you're trying to heal something else, tested
it out and going at it for a short period of time.
I don't see that as a big problem.
What does it jump?
Tudka.
Would you recommend for someone taking it to help the liver
if they're taking.
I've ever been at Penn Bend is all.
So Tudka is a product that just actually came out just a few
years ago.
And it is, it has been tested.
The studies about Tudka has been shown that it's been tested
to really help with liver detoxification.
It helps with phase two detoxification in the liver.
And it can be a good product to help with liver detoxification.
Would milk this will be better.
Well, it depends.
So I mean, we typically use the cheek swab to test for what
product is going to be better.
First, to answer the question, what's the recommended dosage of
Tudka?
It turns out the product itself that you're taking if it's a
cell core Tudka or body bio Tudka.
We typically recommend one to two a day.
Is it going to help with getting rid of Fenn Bend is all
that I've ever been to detoxify it.
So it doesn't damage the liver.
Yes, it can.
Can milk this will be better in some people.
Yes, so milk this will also help with phase two detoxification.
So does our product called phase two, which is the pun one
assist helps with the pun one pathway.
So are any of them contraindicative in hormone positive
breast cancer or any breast cancer?
No, they wouldn't be.
There is nothing negative about Tudka itself as far as
contraindications for cancer patients.
There's not nothing with milk this will that would be a
contraindicative for the breast cancer or any cancer either.
So you couldn't use either.
Next question.
Dr. Jen Simmons did a podcast with Dr. David Broadstein
on iodine recently.
She said that she has converted to his way of thinking on iodine
since talking with him.
I've not listened to that particular podcast, but I do know
that Dr. Broadstein believes it is not just okay, but
important for those with Hashimoto's to have adequate
iodine to support the thyroid.
I was on it previously and have been off of it for about a
year and feel worse without it.
What are your thoughts?
So well, my thoughts are I you can disagree with me, but I
disagree with Dr. Broadstein.
Dr. Broadstein follows the basically the old
naturopathic nutritional functional to raw functional
medicine thought process that I used to follow to that
iodine is essential for the thyroid.
Therefore, anybody wants to support the thyroid should be on
iodine because the thyroid takes iodine to make its T3 and T4
iodine is a functional part of that.
Therefore, it goes with understanding that anybody should be
on iodine to help support the thyroid in making thyroid
hormone, the T3 and T4.
However, study after study after study in the last ten years
have shown that people are getting adequate iodine in their
food.
And the whole light of thinking about iodine was that was
because in the 1940s and 50s, there were a large
populous of people that were iodine deficient.
We weren't getting it in our food because you were eating
locally.
And in the 40s and 50s, people had moved away from eating
vegetation.
So people weren't eating vegetables as much.
They were eating.
That's when after World War II, the easy TV dinners came out
and our food quality plummeted from prior to World War II.
Prior to World War II, people were growing things in the
gardens.
It was encouraged for people to grow their meals, grow enough
food, putting them up.
Canine was very popular.
Women and families were eating foods that they were producing.
They were producing foods on the farm.
In the 50s, things changed dramatically post-World War II.
And then we saw a dramatic rise in nutritional deficiencies
that we never saw before.
Chemicals were used on plants and nutritional value of plants
themselves that people were eating had plummeted.
It was said that the nutritional value of an orange prior to World
War II had 50 times nutritional value that an orange does today.
So our nutritional value of food has changed dramatically
and you could read a lot about that data.
It's straight science.
So there were people that were deficient in iodine.
In fact, there was a part of America that was called the
iodine belt that people were getting iodine.
That's why they started to put iodine in salt.
Unfortunately, they put potassium iodine in salt.
That's the source of iodine that they used.
It's not a good source of iodine.
And that's what most iodine supplements are, or potassium iodine.
It's not a good source of iodine for our body, anyhow.
So it was the line of thinking from nutritionists from the 1960s,
late 60s, on that everybody should be taking iodine.
And you should be making sure that you're taking salt that is
iodized salt because that's how you could get your iodine.
So that line of thinking has continued.
A lot of people, Dr. David Brown said,
he kind of has an ore in the water because he wrote at least one
book on the necessity of iodine.
And he would in order to change his thinking if to recant everything
that he wrote in that book.
Now, I'm not saying that there can't be some truth that there's still people
that are deficient in iodine and need a source of iodine.
But if that was the case, then I would be taking a whole food source of iodine,
not a potassium iodine that's in 99% of supplements out there.
But I would before taking iodine, I would test if I had an iodine deficiency.
The problem has come up is that prior to the use of potassium iodine supplementation
in iodine salt, there really was no autoimmune thyroid.
People did have, so understand thyroid problems.
You can have primary hypothyroidism.
That means you just have a low functioning thyroid.
You don't have an autoimmune disease to the thyroid.
You don't have elevated TPO antibodies.
You don't have elevated thyroid globulin antibodies.
So not having those antibodies, you don't have an autoimmune attack on the thyroid.
Would caused autoimmune thyroidism, Hashimoto's, and caused it to spike
in the 70s, 80s, 90s to its current state, is the use of iodine.
There were several studies on taking people with primary hypothyroidism,
giving them iodine.
And the studies were just, you can't argue with the data.
Every single person with primary hypothyroidism, taking iodine, develop Hashimoto's.
So when you have Hashimoto's, it's a total new game.
So once you have Hashimoto's and you're taking iodine,
iodine is so drawn to the thyroid, is that you will stimulate an immune attack on the thyroid,
taking iodine once you already have Hashimoto's.
So it will make your Hashimoto's worse.
Can a person actually, I was taking iodine and I felt better?
Well, I would say, maybe that's true.
I'm not questioning your subjective data there.
But I would say maybe you should question whether there was other factors
that you don't feel as well that are indifferent to the iodine.
Maybe I'm completely wrong there in your case and maybe you need iodine.
I'm not saying that, but the data is very specific.
That iodine will stimulate an immune attack on the thyroid for those that already have Hashimoto's.
If you don't have Hashimoto's, it will almost surely create a Hashimoto's
and autoimmune thyroid condition to somebody who has primary hypothyroidism.
So I'm not going to argue with Dr. Brownstein.
I'm not going to argue with Jen Simmons.
But the data is very specific and I do have much more on this,
on the autoimmune course.
You guys all have access to that in the last section.
The last module of the autoimmune course is all on thyroid Hashimoto's disease
so you could gather more information on that.
And I do have some of the studies I think published on there as well.
Next question. I have searched for answers to the following question,
but could I find any? So I'm asking you here.
That's exactly what this is for.
So I understand the function of black, sav, blood root, what it is used topically.
But how does it work to help a cancer patient if it's used internally?
So black, sav, blood root, understand, is the name of a supplement.
So the supplement that we have, that's called black, sav, blood root,
maybe shouldn't be called that, okay?
Well, why is it called that?
Well, it does have a, have a burdock root in it.
Graviola powder, which is the leaf of the graviola, chaperale,
and it has blood root powder.
So those four things are all known natural cancer killers.
Blood root is an herb.
So it doesn't grow here in Minnesota, but it grows in different parts of the world.
I looked it up once, trying to look at how I could grow blood root.
And I don't remember all the data that I found, but I gave up on trying to grow it myself.
Burdock root grows everywhere.
And I have enough burdock root, burdock plants, my 20 acre property to probably feed the world in cancer treatment.
So burdock grows everywhere.
It's a deep, deep rooted plant.
Trying to pull a burdock, plant out, and you will, you'd have to get, you know,
the seventh regimen army to help you pull the thing out.
The burdock roots go down, you know, 10, 15 feet into the soil.
It's really, you have to really dig them out to get the root.
It actually made some burdock root, a tincture last year, was it?
Or the year before when we also had black wallets, we have black wallet tree.
So we made black wallets, burdock root, and something else of the tincture mulled.
I think I had, because we grow mulled, and I can't remember something else.
But burdock root is known as a great cancer killer.
Graviola is sour sap.
And it's the leaf of the Graviola plant that's a great cancer killer in itself.
And chaperale is another cancer killer.
The chaperale, I believe, is an seacte, as well as an hoxy.
So those are just four great, natural cancer-killing herbs.
Now, black sap, topical, is actually made from blood root.
So it's basically dried blood root that is made into a sap with some sort of emulsifier.
And then you put that on topically to kill melanoma and other skin cancers.
It could be really good for it as a topical.
I know people who have actually taken the black sap orally, I think it's a waste of money,
because black sap in itself is expensive to buy it made up as a sap.
And you could get the powdered blood root for pennies of the dollar to what you're paying for the black sap.
So that's not a smart way to take it.
But the black sap blood root capsules that you're talking about here
are not just blood root, and it's not sap.
So I don't know why they named it that.
The company named it that.
This company also makes black sap that I recommend the black sap with the MSO for people with topical cancers.
And maybe they did it just to help people understand that this is an oral, quote-a-quote, black sap, well, it's not sap.
And it's not only blood root, but that's just what they named it.
Next question from the chat.
I've been eating about three prunes after dinner to help with elimination.
I also do daily coffee animals.
Are the prunes okay since they're fairly sweet, or do you recommend a different gentle option?
No, I do recommend prunes.
And in your binder, remember you have a page that I might have changed the name of it,
but I used to call it constipation, know-how.
That goes over different things that you could do to help with elimination.
I would say prunes are working. That's a food.
So I would just do that.
Things that would be mild things to help with elimination would be magnesium, taking magnesium before bed.
That can help.
And if prunes are working, then I would just stay with the prunes.
If all else fails in a person is extremely constipated there, having difficult time, having a ball of wood,
that I tell people to go to the super aloe, which is an ortho molecular product.
It's you can do the super aloe 250 or the super aloe 450.
Now people will just say, well, it's just aloe.
I have aloe at home. I'll use it.
Or I think I have aloe capsules, you know, or a liquid aloe player.
Understand there's different varieties of the aloe player.
So typically the aloe that you would have in a capsule or a liquid at home to help heal the gut is called aloe arboressence.
So that's not the aloe that we're talking about.
This is called cape aloe.
That's a totally different variety of aloe.
And what it does is it causes stimulation of your smooth muscles or your intestines.
And it will just literally flush you out.
So I've not had a person that has been constipated that super aloe did not work on it.
So cape aloe is the product that we're talking about.
It's cape aloe.
So cape aloe could be found in the super aloe 250 to super aloe 450.
We have it in a so 250 stands for milligrams per council, 450 as milligrams per council.
We have it a much smaller dose in our, I think it's our phase six or phase six assist.
One of the other ones where it's only like 50 milligram doses.
So it would be for a person who's not, who's not constipated, but wants to just stay regular.
Typically, people don't use high dose cape aloe.
And I would say even 250 milligrams is relatively high dose.
Typically, typically people don't use that high of a dose of cape aloe just on a daily basis.
Typically people are using a much lower dose.
And we have it in some other products too, so you can look up cape aloe.
But I would definitely stay with prunes or magnesium as my first choices.
And then we have a lot of patients that will have a bottle of super aloe in their cupboard,
so that if gosh, I've been called didn't go at all yesterday.
I feel like I'm bloated.
I feel like I need to really clean myself out that they'll use the super aloe.
Now, understand, I do have a number of people that use the super aloe 250 on a daily basis,
and they are just happier than a lot because they feel like they're cleaning out on a daily basis.
And I'm totally okay with that.
There isn't any no negative effects of using it on a daily basis, but usually people don't need to.
Now, remember, you have the seven phases of detoxification course available to you too.
So do look at that and phase six is proper elimination.
So I do have that data, more information about super aloe and things in that.
And other, and I do have, if you can't find your binder, I do have that constipation,
know how information in that phase, in that part of the seven phases of detoxification course as well.
So you'll find more information that I'm talking about right here.
Any other questions?
Okay, well, thanks so much for being with us today.
We will be back next week, so make sure you get your questions in.